federal agents searched the Gibson
guitar plant here in Music City several
hundred Gibson guitar employees got to
go home early today due to an unusual
circumstance a raid by federal agents in
August 2011 the Gibson guitar
corporation was raided by armed agents
from the department's of Homeland
Security and Fish & Wildlife the agents
shut down the factory ordered all
employees off the premises and seized
approximately half a million dollars
worth of wood meant to be used as guitar
fingerboards while no charges have been
filed to date the government accused
Gibson of being in violation of the
Lacey Act an anti trafficking statute
originally passed in the 1900s to
protect fish and wildlife but whose
scope has expanded several times to
include plant life and international
trade the Lacey Act makes it a crime to
import illegally taken products whether
that illegality occurs in the US or the
country of origin in this case the
Justice Department contends Gibson used
an inappropriate tariff code for the
export of guitar fingerboards from India
India is is wanting to ensure that raw
wood is not exported without some labor
content from India rather than using the
tariff code that describes the raw wood
as a musical instrument part which
Gibson did the government's
interpretation of Indian law describes
the wood as veneer because the wood is a
fraction of an inch thicker had the
wooden question been slightly more
finished before it was exported from
India there apparently would have been
no objection from the US government it
has nothing to do with conservation and
have nothing to do with how scarce or
not scarce
rosewood or ebony is and have to deal
with jobs they have raided us come in
with weapons they seized a half a
million dollars worth of product they
shot our factory down and they have not
charged us with anything at this point
it's not up to Gibson or any other
company to decide which laws in India or
Madagascar or whatever country they want
to respect this is an issue about mutual
respect for the rule of law around the
world and that's what the Lacey Act says
that's the
so behind the Lacey Act Gibson has now
been rated twice under the Lacey Act the
first time was in 2009 and that was for
importing illegally logged wood from
Madagascar allegedly and then the second
raid in August of 2011 was in relation
to imports of sawn wood from India we
escalated our due diligence efforts on
wood I mean you know we're pretty
sensitized after being raided so
shocking that they've come back but we
have affidavits from both governments
that with everything that we've done is
lawful and by their law so both
governments have said the transaction
was lawful the US government says it
wasn't but they haven't filed any
charges and they won't allow you a day
in court to hash this out correct the
most recent amendment to the Lacey Act
in 2008 includes a regulation called due
care which requires anyone purchasing or
possessing a wood product to declare the
provenance of every piece of wood in
that product so you got a guitar from
your dad when you travel with that
guitar you have to file a Lacey
Declaration and that declaration has to
have every piece of wood that's in the
guitar named by its Latin name and where
it came from who is going to know that
no one is going to know I mean on an
older guitar you're not going to know
that it's ridiculous if you don't file
that form you're in violation of the
Lacey Act and subject to a hundred
thousand dollar fine and confiscation of
the instrument do individual musicians
need to worry about the Lacey Act and
about declaring their instruments when
they cross international borders the
simplest answer is no the government has
officially stated in an almost
unprecedented action that the government
has no intention to enforce the Lacey
Act against individual owners of musical
instruments there has been a real
disservice done by some
people and not trying to get the truth
out about what individuals do and don't
have to worry about while the government
claims they have no interest in
prosecuting individual guitar owners
individuals have been charged in the
past for obscurely C Act violations like
the case of for small businessman
convicted of felony conspiracy to
smuggle because they brought lobsters
from Honduras to the United States in
clear plastic bags rather than opaque
cardboard boxes as required by Honduran
law despite the fact that this law was
no longer on the books in Honduras all
four served time in federal prison
Senator Rand Paul has taken an interest
in cases of bureaucratic overreach and
addressed the Gibson rate in a
congressional hearing we in my office
are proposing a legislative solution
legislative solutions unfortunately are
usually prospective and may or may not
help you so we're going to have an
amendment to the Lacey Act to remove any
provisions that refer to foreign laws
there is surely a place for laws
promoting conservationism but if the
government won't allow Gibson their day
in court how can it justify punitive
raids and seizures of private property
and if the government is willing to
split hairs over an interpretation of a
foreign country's tariff code how can
assurances that individual guitar owners
won't be prosecuted under the letter of
the Lacey Act be trusted just points out
that this is not about responsible
forestry in and sustainable wood or
illegal logging this is about a
bureaucratic law think about that that's
a blank check for abuse